these days we're pretty constantly
bombarded with trailers posters and
other promotional material for new
releases and major long-running
franchises but there also happen to be a
few part twos that have managed to stay
under the radar and terrifying shark
encounters two fascinating murder
mysteries let's take a look at some of
the sequels you didn't know we're being
made 47 meters down the next chapter
granite 47 meters down wasn't exactly
jaws but audiences gobbled up the
shark-infested film nonetheless this
indie thriller was produced for a mere
5.5 million dollars and it earned over
44 million dollars and naturally with
that kind of return the filmmakers were
only too happy to fund another trip into
the ocean only this time the film
setting is moving from Mexico to Brazil
producer James Harris has promised that
the sequel quote will take the
claustrophobia of cave diving and the
thrill of shark encounters and move
everything to the next level writer
director Johannes Roberts is returning
and while the film will focus on a
different set of heroes
you can probably guess the basics of the
plot a group of girls go searching for
hidden ruins and run into some very
hungry fish Roberts has described the
film as an underwater version of the
descent since the movie will be set
largely inside a series of underwater
caves 47 meters down the next chapter is
due for release on June 28 2019 there
will be swimming there will be screaming
and there will be sharks or more do you
want
men in black it's been over five years
since a men in black last saved Earth
from an alien threat but now Sony plans
on bringing the iconic agents back to
theaters according to Deadline the
studio has their latest entry into the
men in black franchise set for release
on June 14th 2019 but don't expect to
see Will Smith or Tommy Lee Jones
returning instead the film will focus on
a new cast of characters as deadline
explains the studio wants to produce a
spin-off that can reboot and expand the
franchise in the same way that Jurassic
world did a few years earlier this
sci-fi comedy will feature thor ragnarok
stars Chris Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson
alongside returning MIB vet Emma
Thompson mark your calendars and try not
to forget it's happening ladies and
gentlemen if you will look right here
death on the Nile while it may receive
mixed reviews from critics
2017 s Murder on the Orient Express
killed it at the box office earning a
worldwide total of
39 million dollars against the
production budget of 55 million dollars
with that kind of cash it makes total
sense of Hercule Poirot and his epic
facial hair will be making a return to
the silver screen only this time instead
of taking a train ride across the
wintery European landscape he'll be
taking a boat ride through the deserts
of Egypt
Mon Ami on Carl
according to Deadline Agatha Christie
fans can expect to see death on the Nile
sailing into theatres on December 20th
2019 based on the 1973 novel this new
adventure will follow Poirot as he tries
to solve a murder on a riverboat that's
cruising down the Nile it looks like
Kenneth Branagh will both direct and
play the mustachioed detective although
we don't know yet who will be filling
out the rest of the cast however we do
know that Michael Green will be writing
the screenplay not only did he penned
Orient Express but he also wrote Logan
Blade Runner 2049 and all eight episodes
of American Gods talk about a safe pair
of hands
Zombieland - it's been almost the
decades and Zombieland staggered into
theaters earning rave reviews and over a
hundred million dollars worldwide since
then the movie has only grown in
popularity with bands positively
clamoring to see Columbus Tallahassee
Wichita and Little Rock back in action
while there's been talk of making a part
- for quite some time the film was never
able to come to life
but now according to The Hollywood
Reporter a sequel is finally rising up
from development health zombie land - is
set to hit theaters in October 2000 19
and it's bringing pretty much everyone
from the first movie back to the big
screen Jesse Eisenberg Woody Harrelson
Emma Stone and Abigail Breslin are all
returning as his original director Ruben
Fleischer Paul Wernick and Rhett Reese
who penned the first film not to mention
both Deadpool movies are also coming
back we don't exactly know the plot yet
but thr says our heroes will go quote
from the White House to the American
heartland as they faced off against new
kinds of zombies that have evolved since
the first movie as well as some new
human survivors they'll also have to
learn how to get along with one another
as they make a new life for themselves
in a zombie filled Twinkie list world
which is way easier said than done
might want to buckle up you know first
safety I can tell already you are gonna
get on my nerves happy deathday to you
what if you were forced to relive the
same day over and over again Groundhog
Day style and were always killed at the
end of it by some mysterious slasher
villain naturally you'd want to discover
the identity of your masked attacker and
somehow break that vicious cycle written
and directed by Christopher Landon and
starring Jessica Roth is the off
murdered lead tree 2017 s happy death
day was a surprise hit raking in a
hundred and twenty-two million dollars
worldwide and with that kind of success
you know that poor tree is in for
another day of butchery
according to Variety bloom house and
Universal are busy working on a sequel
titled happy deathday to you we don't
know any real plot details yet but
returning leave jessica roth told
collider that happy deathday to you will
be a back to the future type of genre
film where the sequel joins us right
from where we left off we'll get to see
what fresh horror awaits our hero On
February 14 2019